this incident has dramatically brought
home to all of us how dangerous this war
is and the risks of much greater
escalation that won't go away for as
long as the war continues the backdrop
was a day that saw more than 90 missiles
fired by Russia at Targets across
Ukraine it says it shot down 77 of them
among the targets was leviv just 72
kilometers south of Virginia where the
explosion happened most of the Russian
strikes on Ukraine yesterday seems to
have been kh-101 and
kh55 cruise missiles and some Iranian
suicide drones which have been used by
Russia since October but the explosion
that killed two poles inside the Polish
border is our thoughts of being caused
by an S 300 anti-aircraft missile
developed by the Soviets but used by the
ukrainians as air defense you can see it
here from Russian military drills back
in 2018 but the ukrainians have the same
technology now last night an unnamed U.S
intelligence official claimed it had
been a Russian missile that would have
been the first Russian attack on a NATO
country and it triggered good a sequence
of events the Polish government convened
a National Security Council meeting
while NATO gathered information on what
had happened only this morning to Poland
and NATO conclude that the incident was
probably an accident
this is what NATO does it's it's been
what it's been doing since 1949 you know
in this case of the Cold War
um you know the the consequence of
miscalculation was very very high in the
Ukraine situation again with Miss
outgoing
um over the territory to a NATO border I
mean it is a risk but also like I said
there's a bespoke options for dealing
with these
it could have been so much more serious
there have been other near misses in May
Russia bombed the Ukrainian region of
zakar Patia just a hundred kilometers
from NATO member Slovakia's border with
Ukraine and last month a Russian fighter
jet released a missile near a British
aircraft over the Black Sea because of a
technical malfunction if that had been
hit it would have been grounds for an
invocation of Article 5 of the NATO
treaty requiring all member nations
defend Britain potentially leading to
all-out war NATO and the UK say
ultimately Russia is to blame for last
night's incident this wouldn't have
happened if it wasn't Waging War on
Ukraine it was an accident but it's
highlighted dramatically the dangers of
this conflict and how easily it could
escalate